en este vídeo quiero atacar algunas
desigualdades que involucran multiplicar
y dividir por números positivos y
negativos y verás que es un poco más
truculento que solo sumar y restar
números que vimos por ejemplo en el
último vídeo y también quiero
introducirte a otro tipo de notaciones
para describir el conjunto solución de
una desigualdad así que hagamos un par
de ejemplos por ejemplo que tenemos la
desigualdad
- déjenme déjenos corregir lo menos 0.5
x ok y que esto sea menor o igual que
7.5 ok tenemos esta desigualdad de aquí
y cómo lo resolvemos bueno si fuera una
igualdad que es lo que se nos antoja
haría ser bueno pues multiplicar por o
más bien dividir entre menos 0.5 verdad
de tal suerte que del lado izquierdo
quitamos el coeficiente y del lado
derecho ya nos queda un número verdad
sin embargo en las desigualdades no es
tan inmediato ok no es tan inmediato de
hecho cuando multiplicamos o dividimos
por un número negativo
lo que tenemos que hacer es cambiar el
signo de la desigualdad debemos invertir
ese orden y les voy a dar un ejemplo de
por qué esto es cierto por ejemplo todo
el mundo estará de acuerdo que el número
1 es más chico que el número 2 ok eso
eso yo creo que nadie los va a dudar en
estos momentos sin embargo qué pasaría
si nosotros multiplicamos por menos 1
entonces aquí me quedaría menos 1 y del
otro lado me quedaría menos 2 yo te
preguntaría qué número es más chico
bueno pues queda claro que el menos 2 es
más negativo que menos 1 verdad entonces
este número es más pequeño entonces como
puedes darte cuenta si un número es más
grande que el otro entonces al
multiplicarlo por menos uno lo que está
haciendo es volverlo más negativo de
verdad quiere decir que se está
volviendo mucho más pequeño en el
sentido de que se vuelve más negativo y
aquí por supuesto no es una demostración
de por qué al multiplicar por un número
negativo hay que invertir el orden de la
desigualdad sin embargo yo creo que con
esto te sentirás más
como de verdad así que lo que tenemos
que hacer aquí es dividir entre menos
0.5 o multiplicar por algún número que
sea negativo y al y así se invierte la
desigualdad y bueno cuál es el número
por el que hay que multiplicar dividir
bueno en realidad si nosotros
multiplicamos esta desigualdad por menos
2 ya lo logramos verdad y es que en
realidad estoy pensando el 0.5 que es la
mitad de 5 verdad entonces esto es como
menos un medio como cancelo menos un
medio pues con menos 2 así que de ambos
lados multiplicamos por menos 2 de este
lado se quedaría x menos 0.5 x ahorita
checamos la desigualdad y aquí nos
quedaría 7.5 x menos 2 ok y vi la
desigualdad dijimos que se cambia en
este tipo de casos así que en vez de ser
menor o igual va a ser mayor o igual muy
bien entonces vamos a resolver esto de
donde salió el menos 2 insisto de que el
menos 0.5 es como
- un medio ok entonces menos 2 x menos
0.5 es dos veces 0.5 que es una verdad
entonces tenemos simplemente x es mayor
o igual que menos 2 por 7.5 que es menos
2 por 7.5 es 15 ok entonces mi solución
es todos los números que sean más más
grandes o iguales que menos 15 verdad
incluso tú puedes aquí intentar poner el
cero que claramente el cero es más
grande que cualquier número negativo en
particular el menos 15 y yo por ejemplo
puedes intentar el menos 16 verdad si tú
pones menos 16 eso no es cierto que sea
mayor o igual que menos 15 de hecho si
tú pones menos 16 aquí serían menos x
menos más 0.5 por 16 o la mitad de 16 es
8 que claramente no es menor o igual que
7.5 verdad entonces si nosotros fuéramos
a dibujar esta solución
el conjunto solución podríamos pintar
una
real
hay una recta de números reales y
digamos que por acá anda el -15 por acá
andará el menos 16 verdad seguimos del
lado izquierdo y del derecho y acá
tendremos el menos 14 entonces como
gráfica mos nuestra solución primero el
menos 15 si lo incluimos y además nos
tomamos todos los que están a la derecha
de verdad todos los que son mayores o
iguales entonces así es como se vería
graficado pero quizás también has visto
esto como un conjunto solución en
términos de un intervalo que
significaría esto bueno ponemos el menos
15 y como vamos a incluirlo le ponemos
un corchete de un 5
uno de estos paréntesis rectangulares me
parece que son los corchetes verdad
entonces le ponemos un corchete siempre
que queramos
incluir este número y nos vamos a ir
hacia adelante hasta el infinito ok
entonces aquí le vamos a poner el
paréntesis normal y esto es generalmente
cuando ponemos este tipo de paréntesis
es porque no estamos incluyendo este
número de aquí y en realidad el infinito
no lo vamos a incluir el infinito no es
un número verdad no es como que uno
puede decir ahora claro ya llegué al
infinito nunca vamos a llegar al
infinito así es que en general pues el
paréntesis se ocupa para cuando no
incluimos el punto o para cuando estemos
trabajando con infinito ok y quizás
también lo habrás visto de esta forma
con con abriendo una llave en términos o
en notación con juntista verdad esto es
el conjunto de todos los x x es un
número real un número número real
tal que y se pone con una barrita así
tal que x es mayor o igual que menos 15
ok esto también es una forma de expresar
lo mismo esto esto esto y esto es bueno
la forma gráfica estas son formas
equivalentes de ver la solución
el conjunto solución vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo digamos este
75 x es mayor o igual que 125 ok en este
caso por hoy ya ya no vamos a necesitar
multiplicar por números negativos así
que en realidad lo que yo puedo hacer es
dividir de ambos lados sobre 75
dividimos sobre 75 y no hay que cambiar
la desigualdad porque este no fue
negativo recuerda que solo hay que
cambiarlo cuando es negativo entonces
qué es lo que me queda aquí nos queda x
es mayor o igual que 125 sobre 75 muy
bien y bueno ya esta sería la solución
pero si queremos simplificar lo podemos
dividir en el numerador y en el
denominador por me parece 25 porque esto
es 5 veces 25 entonces me queda 5 y
abajo esto es 25 por 3 verdad entonces
me queda 3 larsson el conjunto solución
son los números mayores o iguales que
cinco tercios entonces si lo expresamos
en términos de intervalos pues tenemos
al cinco tercios y le ponemos este este
este corchete porque si lo estamos
incluyendo verdad y nos seguimos todo
derecho hasta el infinito y éste no lo
incluimos porque ni siquiera es un
número como lo grafica mos
nuevamente nuestra recta real muy bien y
ubicamos el 5 3 y 2 que más o menos es
uno y dos tercios entonces por acá andar
el cero por aquí andar el uno por aquí
andar el dos y este es uno con dos
tercios así que anda por aquí este es el
5 tercios y lo que hacemos es tomarnos
todos desde el 5 tercios en adelante
verdad nos los tomamos todos
todos estos y este lo incluimos muy bien
vamos con otro ejemplo más por ejemplo
que tenemos el x sobre menos 3 mayor que
menos 10 novenos entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer aquí este este x entre menos 3
lo podemos pensar como menos un tercio
de x ok entonces esto es menos un tercio
de x keith y para cancelar esto pues
necesariamente tenemos que multiplicar
por menos 3 verdad tenemos que
multiplicar por menos 3 los signos se
cancelan y 3 sobre 3 nos da 1 y haber
del otro lado tenemos que multiplicar
exactamente por lo mismo por menos 3
ahora cómo multiplicamos por un número
negativo que dijimos que el signo de la
desigualdad tiene que cambiar de
orientación entonces en vez de ser mayor
que ahora va a ser un menor que
como nos quedaría finalmente esto se
cancela y me queda x es menor que menos
10 novenos x menos 3 los signos se
cancelan y me queda por ejemplo podemos
cancelar aquí el 3 no y cancelar aquí un
3 y me queda 3 y me queda efectivamente
10 tercios verdad los signos se cancelan
entonces me queda x menor que 10 tercios
y si queremos expresar lo en términos de
conjuntos pues vamos a tomarnos el 10
tercios y éste no lo vamos a incluir
verdad no viene el igual así que le
ponemos este límite de paréntesis y
vamos a ir bajando bajando bajando hasta
menos infinito y como menos infinito no
es un número le ponemos su paréntesis
normal verdad como se grafica nuevamente
tenemos nuestra recta ok no sé por
ejemplo diez tercios son como tres un
tercio entonces por aquí andará el cero
el 2 el 3 y el 4
y estos son tres enteros un tercio
entonces más o menos va a andar por acá
por aquí andará el diez el diez tercios
y éste no lo incluimos puesto dejamos la
bolita abierta y nos tomamos todos a la
izquierda todos a la izquierda así se
grafica mi solución vamos a hacer un
último ejemplo
vamos a hacer un último ejemplo apartado
de lo que ya hemos hecho por ejemplo x
sobre menos 15 es menor que 8 ok
entonces misma
misma técnica como quitamos al menos 15
pues multiplicando por menos 15 de ambos
lados verdad aquí multiplica a x sobre
menos 15 y del otro lado me queda 8 x
menos 15 y nuevamente como como esto fue
multiplicar por un número negativo la
desigualdad cambia de orientación muy
bien entonces ahora es un mayor que esto
se cancela tenemos x mayor que 8 x menos
15 y 8 x menos 15 es 8 x 55 x 8 son 40
llevo 48 x 1 son 8 y 4 son 12 ok
entonces es 120 y con este menos ahí se
lo dejamos muy bien entonces cuál es
como se ve en términos de intervalo pues
empezamos en menos 120 no lo incluimos
así que le ponemos este paréntesis y nos
seguimos derechito hasta el infinito
o bien si lo queremos graficar tenemos
esta recta verdad aquí a lo mejor andará
el menos 120 verdad quizá sacando el 0 y
nos tomamos bueno más bien el ciento
menos 120 no lo tomamos y nos vamos
hacia la derecha verdad entonces puedes
intentar algunos números por ejemplo el
0 el 0 funciona pues sí claro
0 entre menos 15 0 que claramente es
menor que 8 y aunque eso no demuestra
nada puedes intentar cualquiera de estos
números que se encuentren de este lado y
deben funcionar así que espero que esto
te haya resultado bastante útil nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo